hold my teeth
we're gonna talk about this
hello I'm Aria
I'm a tradwife
I've been married for four years
and let me tell you the two reasons why I think tradwives make food
that doesn't really look that great
first off most of us are married to blue collar men
and as a generalization
I'm not saying every blue collar man is like this
blue collar man like their casseroles and their canned green beans
I know this is true for my husband
because whenever I make him a casserole or make him something in a gravy
like beef stroganoff sort of thing
he loves it it might be the ugliest food I have ever seen in my whole life
but he loves it
and it goes on the list of we're making this again
my husband is okay if I make like
fancier foods or like
international stuff
but it really does not go on that list of making this again
because it's a family favorite
the second reason is
this is not true for me
but I suspect it's true for a lot of us tradwives
is that we were not raised in a traditional household
and we were not taught how to cook
so a lot of us are just out here trying to teach ourselves
learn from YouTube
Pinterest whatever
and just winging it
and we don't know how to plate food
and we're just
we're trying our best
so those are the two reasons why
I think that trade wives don't make like fancy food
let me know what you think in the comments